hello and welcome to this video play
interracial no freedom as I'm sorry
in Finlay I know the sky thank we're
friends on Facebook to place the the
classical variation classical set the
right way to college either their old
main line of the petrol we are taking 93
is a completely out of fashion when they
go for this line in the first place they
usually play stuff without the capture
on d5 play 93 immediately or Quincy - or
okay one but this is not a terrible line
of course white taking cannot be bad
it's just that probably on the general
grounds and yeah exchanging on d5 it's
not so testing rookie aid is a possible
line here that's a side line actually
but one that I analyzed a bit for my
from a Petrov project and I felt it is
totally okay it's simpler to play them
taking on c3 why does not have Bishop h7
IG v Queen g4 tactic because at the end
has made only one now I have to make
sure that this tactic doesn't happen now
the bishop he is unprotected and always
have to watch out them this smooth okay
so he does not mind that I potentially
capture on f3 hmm Bishop f3 what's going
on here he will take on b7 I guess
interesting
[Music]
oops so how do we play this I'm a little
bit irritated him it's not that simple I
cannot cover both and I don't really
want to play Queen to c6 it's not
looking like a good move Queen to d7 now
that covers d5 tactically probably have
to do this he just doesn't care about it
really I know I'm taking this Queen h3
get at least a draw and I don't want to
draw anymore of course in this position
so so just b6 how do we how to be handle
this I'm gonna be sick so lame so the
lame move yeah but it's probably right
it's probably correct
okay now I can check check on a 45 hangs
the five is now hanging anyway so
problem keeping this covered
tough to evaluate this pollution I mean
on structural grounds white is just lost
but he has these dynamic possibilities
that might be might make it okay for him
XE form
yeah I'm not not really unhappy about
this development still left queen g4 I
mean White's pawn structure is just the
worst
okay I can't go look the eight and try
to get the d5 pawn back of course what
check take f4 but there's d6 yeah but I
told you I should really want to take on
d5 if you know I want you to play more
actively here Knight a5 night age form
things like that so I check and my rook
is hanging unfortunately and so maybe
route d8 was better
maybe you could you aid was better still
have to move this to d8
yeah ma'am I spent too much time him so
he wants some space for the bishop there
okay um why isn't that hanging yeah that
was a bit lucky in a way that my time
was down I think the position was was
was good I was really surprised that he
had absolutely no care for Bishop takes
a three year that was surprising so yeah
here Queen b3 was played Queen d7 took
me too long really because it's kind of
the only move in some way the engine bay
that says that I can take that is
surprising I thought this would be
possible then that 96's yeah desist
indeed ammonium mmm they would have been
interesting the engine gives equal
probably because I have enough for some
kind of Perpetual but okay Queen d7 is
probably an okay move yeah now I thought
he would play 95
I mean allowing Bishop takes the f3
looks looks odd the engine doesn't mind
maybe it is just that he has enough that
he has enough dynamic possibilities as I
said in the game it wasn't entirely
clear to me I mean White's pawn
structure is just awful yeah he's got
yeah
ice double isolated pawn aged to a two
and so on but he's got the bishop a and
my light squares are weak if I would be
better developed I would be clearly
better and the way it was it was
probably a yeah probably equally so
Bishop here and he went c4 yeah okay
c4 is most dynamic choice the engine
wants to check and take a fire I
couldn't bring myself to do that I just
wanted to get pieces out I think knight
c6 is a good human
so 196 it took and now
yeah checks and then 97 but the
immediate 97 must be fine I mean now it
must be good for black hair cannot
cannot really believe it
look d8 maybe immediately it's better I
mean that is possible to just pick up
the pawn I felt on the e-file there's
something I can do and the way it turned
out I mean the engine likes my play
again this okay f5 is a blunder but I
mean white has just I've got the perfect
pawn structure and why it has five weak
pawns that cannot be good I'm still
didn't quite see it like I'm winning
like the engine says but maybe it is
said wherefore is very weak there's
Queen h3
yeah I was a bit concerned also because
of the time for sure okay guys thanks
for watching